I like to just play you some of the
Montage of clips of the CDC director
Rachelle wolenski talking about vaccines
over time and get your reaction you are
protected against severe covid
hospitalization and death and are even
protected against the known variants
including the Delta variant circulating
in this country we have seen now
evidence that we've been looking at just
over the last week or so that has
demonstrated that the vaccine is
starting to wane in its Effectiveness
against infection just last month the
CDC and the FDA both said we would not
need booster shots what specifically has
changed in the data that has changed
your guidance
right several things so first in the
last six weeks we have seen Delta in
this country I don't want to say never
but we are not necessarily anticipating
that you will need this annually a new
vaccine with a new approach for most
Americans that means one covid-19 shot
once a year each fall we are simplifying
our message the message is you need to
get your fall booster vaccine so go
ahead and get it what do you think of
the job that the CDC in Rochelle lynskey
have done as it pertains to the vaccine
rollout
I think it's been very poor and deeply
troubled it's the characteristics of a
speaker who's decided what she wants the
public to do and then reasons back to
the sort of messaging that she should
deliver rather than somebody looking at
the scientific facts and just telling
you what we know and what we don't know
and what we still uncertain we can go
back to the beginning the first six
months of 2021 as vaccine rollout
started to take place you know in the
first four months we were Supply
constrained meaning not everyone who
wanted one could get one right away we
made a number of mistakes around who
should be prioritized we prioritized a
lot of young healthy people over older
people we made mistakes about dose two
the United Kingdom stretched those two
out which actually provides more durable
antibody levels and has better safety
than putting the two doses together
those doses were arbitrarily picked very
close together because we needed the
trial to result quickly in 2021 by the
summer of 2021 it was a parent from
Provincetown Massachusetts and other
instances that you would get people who
were vaccinated were still able to catch
the virus and transmit the virus that
means all the mandates that happened in
the fall which was when Biden pushed the
mandates were medically unethical
because you cannot compel an
intervention on a third party if it
provides sorry you cannot compel a
medical invention on somebody unless
there is a benefit to third parties but
by the fall of 2021 we knew that that
wasn't the case now I want to point out
we could have made Pfizer answer the
question in the randomized trial Pfizer
ran in 2020 we could have asked them to
swab people randomly and their
households randomly and we would have
had an estimate of transmission but over
and over again you'll see that to some
degree both administrations give the
companies the benefit of the doubt the
easiest path forward now let's talk
about boosters this country is unique
that we have a singular focus on
boosting everybody from 12 year olds to
six month olds to 86 year olds whereas
in Europe a number of nations have
focused primarily on older vulnerable
people that makes a lot of sense the
European strategy our strategy does not
make sense not supported by evidence
she's being criticized by people like
Paul offit who he himself makes vaccines
and her rhetoric throughout all this is
always too certain and States things
that she does not know to be true I mean
there are video clips of her saying we
know you can't spread the virus she
didn't know that to be true when she
said it and it turned out not to be true
I want a contrast what the official line
or advice is about the vaccines with
what you are saying because what it more
or less is and I'm going to play the
clip of Rochelle wolinski in a second
talking about myocarditis and and
display some of the cdc's messages about
this but it's basically like okay this
is a my there's there's a mild risk but
in the big picture uh you know you can
get myocarditis from the infection
itself there's lots of other bad things
that can happen from the infection
itself so we need to just simplify the
message and say you're better off
getting the booster than not so let me
play this clip from Rochelle wolenski
and then have you respond to that line
of argumentation parts of this rare but
mild myocard I just come in and we heard
about this yesterday at the advisory
committee on immunization practices
yesterday but what we do when we do this
is we look at the risk and we look at
the benefits and to just put this in
perspective if we have a group of 12 to
17 year olds who were working to
vaccinate over the next four months and
we can vaccinate a million of them which
would be great strides over the next
four months we could expect 30 to 40 of
these mild self-limited cases of
myocarditis and for that if we were to
vaccinate all one million we would avert
8 000 cases of covid 200
hospitalizations 50 ICU stays and one
death and so we weigh the risks as well
as the benefits these extraordinary
benefits of vaccines as we make these
recommendations and it is why we at CDC
have made the recommendations to
vaccinate and had co-signers from so
many other medical organizations
including the American Heart Association
so that on its face that argument makes
sense is there something wrong with her
math
yes that's exactly right so I mean her
premise is correct that every time you
take any medical product you gotta weigh
the potential upside against the
potential downside and even if there's
downside if there's more upside it's
still in your best interest to take it
so we all agree on that premise but the
problem is there are errors in her math
uh all of their math is nothing but
errors a few things they conceptually
get wrong one is that you don't have to
give in in their modeling a lot of the
times it's all or nothing it's either
four boosters or no shots at all I
personally think that the vast majority
of adults benefit from dose one dose two
is when I start to struggle with from 20
year old men and those three and dose
four you know I have different cut
points you know so it can vary by dose
depending on your modeling number two we
only really know with sort of good
Precision the reduction in severe
disease in the first two doses that's
what we tested in a randomized fashion
for boosters and for the fourth the
bivalent booster we're doing sort of
retrospective looks in other words we we
don't actually run an experiment to see
what the efficacy is we just let people
get it and we go after the fact and say
hey let's compare people who got it to
people who didn't get it and see how
they do okay let me bring up like this
this slide real quick because I know
that you you analyzed this this is a CDC
slide uh and it's to the point that
you're say you're talking about they're
saying that per million doses of the
this is of the bivalent booster uh in 12
to 17 year olds over six months there's
the numbers of hospitalizations ICU
admissions prevented one zero to one
death permit prevented and then in red
at the bottom zero myocarditis cases so
that's the message coming from the CDC
but you're saying that these studies are
just they're garbage they're not
designed properly yeah so I mean this is
a model it's based on like all the
models we've had in the pandemic that
you know wildly inaccurate oftentimes
it's based on your assumptions and so
what they're assuming is rape
hospitalization from the past that are
going to go forward into the future
unchanged but of course that's going to
be different because more people have
hadn't recovered from covet so that's
going to be lower what they assume is a
vaccine Effectiveness so that this
bivalent booster will lower your risk of
severe disease that they're actually
getting from an older age group and
extrapolating to a younger age group
they're getting it from this sort of
backwards looking kind of study that has
a bias in it and that bias of course you
know Zach and Nick the bias is that
people who choose to get the booster are
different than those who don't in other
ways than the booster I mean they're
usually more precautious people they're
people who may have higher socioeconomic
status they may more likely to be
liberals who live in certain cities you
know for instance and those other
differences might play the role not the
by villain booster itself so you have a
sort of dubious estimate of
hospitalization dubious estimate of
vaccine efficacy extrapolating to a
younger age group and then let's talk
about the harm Side Of The Ledger she
says zero harms out of the 48 000 doses
but they can't actually believe the harm
will really be zero it will be something
when you give it to more people and
allow more time for follow-up my best
guess as to what that something will be
is one in ten thousand because that's a
very nice estimate from the third dose
in in roughly this age group from the
Kaiser Permanente group so
again you know these types of exercises
modeling in science it's the most
malleable science you can bend and flex
it and I can make my own analysis that
would probably reach a different Tipping
Point than hers the problem is that the
person doing this modeling has a already
decided on the policy they've already
decided that these vaccines have to be
given to this age group and then they do
the modeling and that's very problematic
because if we know where we want to go
we can get the model to give us the
result is there any world where this you
know in an alternate universe how would
this have been accomplished how would
quality Studies have been accomplished
because you you do understand like I can
understand from their perspective we're
in an emergency situation it's a
pandemic people are dying getting
hospitalized all the time so we don't
have time to do these high quality
randomized control trials might be the
argument is there anything to that and
you just kind of have to deal with the
uncertainty yeah so I think it's a
Perpetual argument and there's always
two things they say we don't have the
money and we don't have the time the
money I think we'll all concede they
have because Pfizer and modern have 100
billion reasons they can make this
happen the time is the question how long
do these studies take and my answer is
the following simple thing they debuted
this by valent booster in the fall I
believe in September and we still have
14 uptake nationally in age groups so
you know what's the point of rushing
something that nobody wants anyway the
next thing I'd say is that randomized
studies actually don't take as much time
as you think just think about the
initial vaccine trial which was launched
sort of in the summer of 2020 and yield
a result by the Fall
um if you increase the number of people
you give it to you'll get a result even
faster
I think it's inexcusable that they don't
do they don't make the company do those
studies the company is going to make
money for you know year after year
billions of dollars they can afford to
do it we can have the infrastructure to
do it and by doing those studies I think
you will learn the reality and my guess
is the reality is that the the benefit
of these products year after year after
year is going to be smaller than what
they think it is hey thanks for watching
that excerpt from our conversation with
vinay Prasad about U.S Public Health
mRNA vaccines and future threats that
the Precedence set by cobit emergency
measures might pose to our civil
liberties you can check out the full
conversation by clicking on the link in
the description and catch these
conversations streamed live to recent TV
every Thursday at 1 pm Eastern see you
next time